I want to talk to you about something
very very serious and we need to be
looking at the data that I'm going to
present to you today and it has
everything to do with a rigged election
but not a rigged election in Hillary
Clinton's favor in fact quite the
opposite
we've looked at exit polls and a number
of data analysts have looked at exit
polls from the November 8th presidential
election there are four key battleground
states that Hillary Clinton ultimately
lost according to the vote counts but
one according to the exit polls okay
North Carolina Pennsylvania Wisconsin
and Florida had Hillary Clinton won
those states she would have won the
presidential election Hillary Clinton
also won the National exit poll by three
point two percent but as you've been
probably seeing she is only ahead in the
popular vote which she did win by
somewhere around half a percentage point
let me give you some of the numbers and
then we're really going to dig into this
and stay with me because this is
absolutely huge Greg Palast is flat-out
saying this election was stolen from
Hillary Clinton I'm not saying that I'm
saying I want to present the data to you
and then we'll hear what you have to say
and what else comes with this exit polls
were done in 28 states in 23 of those
states the discrepancy between the exit
poll and the actual reported vote count
favored Donald Trump so when we look at
exit polls versus reported vote counts
in five states it was an error or a
discrepancy we will call it or an
inaccuracy in Hillary Clinton's favor in
23 of those 28 states it was a
discrepancy in Donald Trump's favor and
in 13 of those 23 the discrepancy
exceeded the margin of error of the exit
poll now some people might be saying
David we can't trust polls look at what
happened before the election you were
fundamentally misunderstanding how exit
polls are done exit polls have nothing
to do with pre election of opinion polls
about who people say they're going to
vote for likely voters registered voters
eggs
polls are widely considered to be
accurate absolutely within the margin of
error let's take a look at this image
from TD MS research okay and if you're
not watching I'll basically tell you
what are the key issues here if you look
at North Carolina you will see in the
third column that don't Donald Trump
lost North Carolina by two in the exit
polls yet one by three point eight in
the vote count that is a five point
eight point swing relative to the exit
polls is this proof of some kind of
fraud well no it isn't but that's a big
difference look at Pennsylvania in
Pennsylvania Trump lost by four point
four in the exit polls but won by one
point one in the vote count that is a
five point five percentage point swing
look at Wisconsin where Donald Trump
lost by three point nine percent in the
exit polls and won by zero point nine
percent that is a four point eight
percent swing and Florida which is often
one of the closest of all states Donald
Trump lost by one point four percent in
the exit polls won by one point three
percent in the vote count that is a two
point seven swing now this isn't my
opinion or that of anybody in particular
when the vote count varies from the exit
polls by more than the margin of error
it is considered an indicator of
election fraud or irregularities this is
not David Pakman saying it this is not
Pat Forde saying it although by all
means I'll allow him to say it if he
wants to this is the US Agency for
International Development which actually
states in last year's booklet a
discrepancy between the votes reported
by the voters which is what exit polls
are and official results may suggest
that the results have been manipulated I
want to get out ahead of one reaction
from right-wingers that there will be
which as I mentioned before the
pre-election polls were wrong how can we
trust exit polls a trumpeter that I
personally know over the weekend Pat
said to me dad's that polls are bogus
look at the pre-election polls an exit
poll is conducted completely differently
than opinion polls it is two different
different things in exit polls
historically have been very accurate if
you look at Florida in 2000 if you
adjust for the hundred and eighty 1000
rejected ballots by Katherine Harris the
exit polls were spot-on in how they
differed from what was the official vote
count and there are many examples Ohio
in 2004 this is a real concern Pat this
is really the irony of all ironies right
because Trump beforehand was saying that
the election was gonna be ready might
have been but yeah you're not gonna see
Hillary Clinton knew that I mean she's
not going to question the integrity of
the vote after the fact
no and it's going to depend on people
like us and people like those in our
audience and the bloggers that are
starting to look at this to investigate
because the numbers are very very
suspect let me know your thoughts take a
look at the data we're linking to it in
the description to this YouTube video if
you're listening on the radio or
watching on TV anywhere else you can
find this YouTube clip on our youtube
channel youtube.com slash the david
pakman show look at the data yourself
these are irregular highly irregular
results and they are mostly in states
where there was surprised about what the
official vote totals were and of course
we know about all sorts of people
scrubbed from the voter rolls in one of
these states North Carolina we've got
all sorts of reports about very weird
things going on lo and behold we've got
exit polls historically dead accurate
exit polls that really don't make any
sense let's look into this let's keep in
touch about this Omaha Steaks sent me a
great package of steaks and it was
really tremendous I mean big-league guys
I'm really talking about it here I
shared it with my friend Evan who is
sort of a connoisseur and he really
enjoyed it and it is so convenient to go
on the Omaha Steaks website and for
$49.99 get the family gift pack when you
enter the code Pakman in the search bar
you get 77% off the gift pack and just
for our listeners for under 50 bucks you
get to filet mignons to top sirloins for
boneless chicken breasts for burgers a
12 ounce package of all beef meatballs
and of course you need the fixings
including potatoes au gratin caramel
apple tartlets and the Omaha steak
seasoning that many people are aware of
people are talking these days I've heard
from any number of people about that go
to Omaha Steaks comm enter my code
Pakman in the search bar and add the
family gift pack add it to your cart 77%
savings it is
great gift as well